ben affleck and jennifer lopez are
making plans for forever it just turned
out to be something really magical a
source tells e.t the couple can't wait
to spend the rest of their lives
together and know that they were
destined to be together quote an
engagement is on the table and it has
been an ongoing conversation i've heard
you say so many times that you are a
hopeless romantic and you still believe
in love you believe in marriage you
still believe in all of those absolutely
why wouldn't i of course jen and ben
famously known as benifer recently
reignited their flame 17 years after
they called off their engagement in
2004.
it was my first like adult heartbreak we
were about to get married it didn't work
out and it was just a bad heartbreak it
was like
a tough one for me now e.t source says
the love birds are incredibly supportive
of each other quote ben is jen's number
one fan and he completely champions her
and always tells her how great she is
i do love that i love it the 49 year old
oscar winner proved it tuesday night at
the 2022 iheart radio music awards
[Applause]
that's ben cheering on his leading lady
with his son samuel and jlo's daughter
emmy as she accepts the icon award my
mom's just like she's amazing she's such
a powerful human being it's insane if
all that wasn't supportive enough just
check out the last duel star making a
quick cameo in jen's music video for her
ballad marry me
baby you're my shelter
shelter from a broken paradise
i couldn't dream it any better if i
tried
and last month at the marry me premiere
ben was right by the triple threat side
packing on the pda this is just a good
date night it's a great date night we're
super happy
um
what can i tell you we're just
having a good time i would be remiss if
i didn't say you were standing taking
photos in front of a sign that says
marry me
it's very big i didn't really realize
how big this is
now etysor says ben and jen actively
talk about what didn't work in the past
and use those experiences to strengthen
their relationship now for the future
and for the sake of themselves and their
families
quote they are committed to having a
healthy everlasting relationship
it's exciting of course ben was
previously married to jennifer garner
whom he shares three kiddos with
sixteen-year-old violet
thirteen-year-old seraphina and
ten-year-old samuel
e.t soar says the exes get along well
and the 13 going on 30 star is
understanding and supportive of ben's
relationship
quote at the end of the day she just
wants what's best for the kids and for
things to be seamless and unproblematic
she wants everyone to be happy and
healthy and her kids are always the
priority
[Music]
you